[Music]
packed with cooking tips information and
100 recipes to take your life on right
now it's all about cooking with chili
[Music]
for me chilies are an incredible
ingredient in The Cook's Arsenal capable
of transforming dishes adding excitement
heat and a wonderful taste I'm going to
show you how to get the grips with their
intense flavor first up red mullet with
sweet chili sauce
is about being adventurous and having
the confidence to go off peace and being
a little bit more daring so when you
start combining peanuts chili flakes and
this amazing fish red mullet trust me
you're in for an amazing treat
we're going to make a really nice light
sweet chili sauce
first off your chili off with the top in
half
and those seeds inside are very powerful
incredibly hot
but full of flavor garlic
two cloves of garlic
slice the garlic nice and thin
so it helps the puree
chillies in the pasta water garlic in
the salt and it will touch
sugar
in
and then start grinding
push down first
[Music]
salt and the sugar
really helps to puree the chili and the
garlic
sauce always a base
to a chili sauce two tablespoons in
a touch of rice wine vinegar
fish sauce gives it the saltiness the
vinegar gives it a nice acidic wake up
three tablespoons
of olive oil
nice
mix that up beautiful look at the colors
incredible now spring onions I want the
texture
and the crunch spring onions in
coriander slice it once
in
fresh lime
and that goes brilliantly with the red
mullet just really wakes up the chili
the garlic and reminds the sauce that
we're serving with fish now taste
hmm
wow that's delicious look at that
beautiful
no longer that chili sauce sits there
the better it gets now for the peanuts
and chili it's going to coat the top of
the red mullet
peanuts in
salt
in that helps to really grind the
peanuts down some beautiful dried chili
flakes creates a nice sort of warm heat
I'm using fresh chili for the sauce but
dried chili flakes for the coating which
will really crunch up when cooking just
a little bit of the coriander
mix the coriander in to the peanuts and
look I like them quite textured I don't
want them too small as a powder
otherwise they'll burn but crushed
lightly to coat the fish with the chili
and peanut seasoning in a separate Bowl
beat two eggs along with a splash of
fish sauce
take your fillet lay in your red money
dip it in shake up your peanuts
and then in and make sure you push that
down
cover that red Monet
oh beautiful
now make sure that Pan's really nice and
piping hot if we put the fish in and the
Pan's cold
all those wonderful peanuts and chili
just going to slide off the fish so we
need to sear it in and get it nice and
crisp in and lay away from you
beautiful
[Music]
hand starts getting a little bit too hot
get your olive oil
and just Place Another teaspoon of olive
oil around the outside so it starts to
heat up as it hits the center and it
really helps to stay so much more in
control
and turn
nice and gently
you want that nice sort of toasted
sauteed crispness which adds A really
lovely flavor
tilt the pan and just baste
the top of the red mullet with a really
nice piping hot olive oil we've got that
really nice roasted Crunch and it goes
brilliantly with that soft sweetness of
that fish inside gas off and just leave
them sitting in there and finish with
lime and just go over each one
now and take them out
in the sauce
touch on the bottom
and the tail of each fish
now to round that off
serving some fragrant rice
broccoli
amazing and there you have a delicious
peanut encrusted red mullet with a
wonderful sweet chili sauce cooking with
chilies isn't all about blow your head
off heat this dish uses the exciting
Taste of a chili but has a deliciously
elegant and subtle flavor
as you become more confident using
chillies you'll find they can transform
your cooking chilies are a great way of
making dishes exciting and vibrant here
are three quick recipes that are full of
flavor and come with a kick
first up pasta with tomatoes and
cherries and chilies
[Music]
for the spicy sauce slice Anchovies and
garlic
[Music]
dried chilies great for keeping in the
cupboard to add a hit of heat on demand
then add the anchovy all to a hot pan
and Fry the chopped ingredients
add half cherry tomatoes
chopped black olives and salted Capers
cook to combine the flavors
in a separate pan boil dry spaghetti
another great store covered staple
when the pasta is tender but still firm
drain add to the sauce with a splash of
the water it's full of starch which
gives a great silky consistency
then season with pepper and top with
basil
packed with big bold flavors and ready
in under 20 minutes pasta with tomatoes
anchovy and chilies
my next deliciously different chili
recipe is grilled corn with Chipotle
chili butter
[Music]
foreign
first the topping chopped coriander
then add softened butter
soak Chipotle chilies in hot water these
are dried jalapenos which have an
amazing Smoky flavor
drain and chop
[Music]
together and season
next fry corn on the cob in olive oil
you want a really wonderfully charred
flavor
when colored add water to steam through
[Music]
to eat smother the cobs in the butter
and crumble over Lancashire cheese
easy to eat grilled corn with Chipotle
chili butter and utterly delicious Smoky
treat
my final recipe is a chili classic
jerk chicken
[Music]
foreign
start by making the intense jerk
marinade
first Scotch bonnet chilies they may be
small but pack real heat and a fruity
punch
then chop garlic
and fresh thyme
[Music]
for spice add ground cloves
cinnamon nutmeg
and allspice
season with salt and pepper and combine
with olive oil
[Music]
next score chicken legs so the hot spicy
flavors get deep inside the meat
rub thoroughly with the jerk mix and
marinade
add olive oil to a hot dish
[Music]
Brown the marinated chicken for 10
minutes
then add Worcestershire sauce
cover and cook in the oven at 220
degrees for 20 minutes
[Music]
hot spicy jerk chicken easy to make and
Finger Licking Good
three different chilies
three amazing flavors
three irresistible dishes
[Music]
next five more of my 100 tips that'll
make your life easier in the kitchen
first up how to deseed chili to get the
seeds out hold it upright and just rub
the chili between your hands the seeds
are incredibly hot you're just releasing
them from the inside
tapping it down
and then again just a final little rub
now cut the top off and then
just open up
and look
they come out like little miniature
Smarties
and there
cut the little bottom bit off
amazing
next a great tip for using spare chilies
using string to tie together the stalks
then simply hang in your kitchen in just
a few weeks you'll get your very own
dried chilies great crumbled into dishes
for adding heat on demand chilies are
surprisingly versatile if you love them
in savior dishes my tip is to try adding
them to melty chocolate ganache for
chocolate chili truffles or sprinkled
over fresh fruit like mango or
watermelon a great tip to prevent
burning sensitive skin when working with
chilies to get rid of that spice and
that heat on your fingers a little bit
of lemon squeeze a little bit of lemon
juice and that instantly gets rid of the
heat fresh lemon juice
spice up your drinks for a Mexican twist
add a dash of hot chili sauce to beer or
using cocktails to give your drink a
very different sort of Kick
this is my ultimate cookery course 100
recipes to stay your life on I'll be
showing you an amazing spicy beef salad
take a little teaspoon of your dressing
and just go over the beef but first The
Secret of cooking fantastic food is to
start with great ingredients the more
you know personally about where your
ingredients are from and how they
produce the better so don't be scared
ask lots of questions and learn and when
it comes to chilies there's no one
better to ask than chili grower Joanna
Plum who's been farming chillies from
mild to mind blown for over 11 years I
eat chilies all the time every single
day she grows over 60 Types on her farm
and really knows her poblanos from a
habaneros
people think that chilies are all about
heat actually it's about Flavor as well
some are sweet some are aromatic and
they can be used in so many different
dishes when you go shopping and you're
looking for a chili what should you be
looking for what you want to do is look
at the chili and it needs to be nice and
firm and glossy generally the bigger the
chili the milder it's going to be the
smaller the chili the hotter and if it's
small and wrinkly like this one it's
going to blow your socks off another way
to tell if a chili is hot or not is to
split it open and smell it if it's a
super hot chili it'll clear your sinuses
the heat of a chili comes from an oil
called capsaicin and that is
concentrated mainly at the top of the
chili where the seeds are now when
you're cooking with a chili and you want
the flavor of the chili but not too much
of the heat start with just using the
bottom of it as you get closer to the
seeds that chili is going to get hotter
so if you remove the seeds that also
does remove some of the heat there's
thousands of varieties out there because
they cross pollinate very very easily
and that's why the world's hottest chili
is always changing
Joanna's right with over 200 types
available all with different flavors
Aromas and of course levels of heat it's
important to buy what you like here are
my top chilies whatever your desired
kick
at the mild end poblano these are great
for stuffing have a delicate flavor and
often used in Mexican dishes
starting to get hot the jalapeno when
they're green they're like spicy bell
pepper the redder they are the sweeter
they are bird's eye where they really
start to pack a punch long thin and
pungent they're great in Thai Dishes and
are often green or red and at the top
end the habanero these Lantern shaped
demons have a delicious fruity taste
under the firecracker of the chili World
another way to use chilies is to smoke
them and to make chipotle what it is
it's just a Mesquite smoked red jalapeno
it smells fantastic you can almost get
that like Smoky bacon sort of flavor out
of it so you would use this and anything
that you would slow cook so you're
eating a chili and it's really too hot
for you the best way to get rid of that
heat is to drink some milk or a dairy
product like yogurt whatever you do
don't go for water or for beer don't be
frightened of trying new types of
chilies in your cooking experimenting
with these amazing fiery beasts is a
great excuse for getting hot-headed in
the kitchen
they give you a natural high much like
when you've been exercising so your
endorphins are released and you just
feel good chilies make you happy and
they're also an aphrodisiac
South East Asian Chefs they're brilliant
are balancing the hot spices of chili
with sweet sour and salty flavors
if you want a new Twist on a favorite
dish spice it up with chili
my next recipe is super simple to make
but have wonderful depth and complexity
of flavors spicy beef salad
chillies if you use them confidently
they can really add a new dimension to
the style of cooking but the real trick
is finding that balance of flavors that
really suits you because that's the most
important part
so this is the most amazing sirloin you
can see it's got that wonderful marble
for me the secret behind this is cooking
it quickly season the steaks generously
salt and pepper
push that seasoning in to the sirloin
take the sirloin out the fridge
literally 20 minutes before you want to
cook them so it gets up to room
temperature they cook more evenly but
more importantly you can actually season
right inside the steak this little bit
of fat down here season that as well
because that is what we want to roast
and get that really nice and rendered
olive oil in tablespoon roll that round
as it starts to smoke in with the steaks
into the pan
and lay away again into the pan and lay
away if you don't hear that noise the
minute those steaks hit the pan don't
put them in so the secret now is getting
that color on the steak turning it once
and once only and cooking it for two and
a half minutes each side what I want to
do is to get that bit of fats rendered
so it adds a lot more flavor just hold
the stake down like that and that starts
to melt the fat which makes it so much
more tender there should be no white fat
left anywhere
turn them over really important to have
that stake up to room temperature before
you start cooking it so the inside is
nice and warm so he spend less time in
the pan and more time cooling down
really important
now two fingers touch
it goes in it says rare I'm happy for
them to be rare Because by the time I
let them rest
I'm going to go back to medium rare
it'll continue cooking out onto a plate
and let them rest
one
two
get my juices over
don't waste that really important
next the spicy dressing take the seeds
out of a chili to reduce the heat by
rubbing it in your hands and tapping
until the seeds fall out cut it in half
and just chop it
in
garlic and chili Works brilliantly a
quick way of peeling it to get your
knife and just
slam it down pops out very very quickly
in little touch of salt
rub
start going around in circles first
you'll see it pouring
nice clear that off
now we've got the heat in there from the
chili and that richness from the garlic
two teaspoons of palm sugar this is
where it starts to have that nice sweet
sour effect
fish sauce fresh lime this is a simple
fresh chili dressing and it was
something I fell in love with in Vietnam
and Cambodia because it was just so easy
give that a little mix and dissolve the
sugar quick taste
wow right vegetables
great fuss-free way to get super thin
ribbons of carrot is to use a veg peeler
when they're that thin they take the
vinaigrette so much better and radishes
just slice them down at an angle
lovely give another dimension of the
salad and use a banana shallot they are
incredibly mellow
very sweet
across
just chop up
the shalom
and mix that through I want some
Sweetness in there now little Vine
Tomatoes slice them in half tomatoes in
shallot radish carrots and tomatoes next
peel and sliced cucumber chopped spring
onions and Shred baby gem lettuce and
then finally get some fresh mint it's
young mint so you don't need to take all
those stalks off all you do is hold a
bunch upside down and then take it for a
little trim
and just chop that once through
look at that nice minted salad a couple
of tablespoons of dressing don't flood
the salad with the dressing you can
always add but we can't take it away now
really mix that dressing in there make
sure all that chili and garlic and palm
sugar wraps around that salad beautiful
onto the plate the steaks rested it's
now nice and medium rare that little bit
of fat we don't want to find that in the
salad just slice that off that serves
its purpose
kept that steak nice and moist
slice going with the grain it's almost
like slicing through butter and look
inside
beautiful pink you slice the beef too
thinly then it goes Stone Cold and more
importantly all the goodness runs out of
it nice thick slices
get the beef and start placing it around
the salad
take a little teaspoon of your dressing
the rest of your salad
sit there on top and finish it off with
some toasted peanuts peanuts in
now there's nuts are really toasted nuts
on
get another pan and just
a crush
once they've cooled down
just run them through with a knife
I can hear how crunch they are another
texture under the taste of the salad
and then from there sprinkle
finally take that just finish it with a
little
tablespoon of that sauce and there is
one tasty very well textured spicy beef
salad
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons top tips and
100 recipes to stay your life on and
you'll literally be cooking yourself
into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details go on get cooking
right now it's all about making it easy
[Music]
making it easy for yourself in the
kitchen means using the time you have
effectively
and the one thing that can really help
you do that is your freezer
[Music]
my recipe for meatballs is so versatile
it can be used to make a dozen amazing
dishes one of my favorites is meatballs
in fragrant coconut broth
having a freezer of home-cooked
delicious food ready to go can be a real
Lifesaver it means you never have to
compromise on Flavor these meatballs are
delicious but more importantly they
freeze so well
first off get your pan on and start
sweating off the onions and your garlic
this recipe involves making the
meatballs the classic way but the
exciting part
is actually cook them in coconut milk
and it gives a really nice new dimension
to a sort of soft Rich Sumptuous
meatball
chop the onion nice and finely giving
those slices very close together close
to the slices the finer the onions
cut it back down at an angle slice down
just chop I want the onions nice and
fine because I want some finesse to
these meatballs The Secret of a really
good meatball is the texture getting
that balance right
between the minced beef the breadcrumbs
the milk
and the seasoning a couple of cloves of
garlic slice of garlic really nice and
thinly
nice pan nice and hot a tablespoon of
olive oil quite generous with the olive
oil
onions and garlic in a little touch of
salt and pepper
with your mints open it up a little bit
and sort of cut it out that's salt
and pepper
for me
a good meatball is all about the the
softness the texture of that Rich beef
and the way it sort of melts in your
mouth you can color it on the outside
but you want it nice and soft and sort
of rich in the center mix that in
beautifully
and then paste it back out again I've
got some really nice dried chili flakes
I'm going to season the onions with the
chili flakes chili flakes in
cook that out for two minutes
I'm gonna add some milk
[Music]
take your breadcrumbs make a little well
three four tablespoons of milk that
makes a sort of nice slightly doughy
texture but it lightens the texture of
the meatball
place that in
add the onions your garlic and your
chili in there as well
nice put your hands in there and start
mixing them
if you've got the right amount of milk
and breadcrumbs it doesn't mean binding
with an egg
don't make them too small
problem with making them too small is
the fact that they dry out quickly just
the size of a golf ball
a little bit bigger
nice
getting a really nice tight squeeze that
stops IT from breaking up
it always pays to double the recipe and
spend a bit more time making extra
meatballs so you can freeze a batch
ready for another time give the pan a
little wipe out
don't wash out that pan we've got that
flavor from the onions the garlic at the
bottom look at that pan nice and hot
Taste of olive oil in there
place them
the top of your pan
nice and gently
sit them in the oil
get a palette knife and go underneath
them and just sort of
tilt the pan and let the pan cook the
back of the meatball we're going to add
some heat coriander seeds
slightly spicy and peppery just to give
a really nice flavor to the coconut milk
and next some cardamom seeds three or
four onto the board knife on
and no touch of turmeric into the center
of the pan that's going to give it a
really nice spicy flavor
a little pinch cinnamon
all the time you're doing this those
meatballs are just getting tastier and
tastier a couple of dried chilies let
them Infuse in that oil
and then some lemongrass just take the
back of your knife and sort of Beat It
Down that starts to release all that
lovely sort of fragrance like someone's
just let off the most amazing fragrant
air freshener in for the lemongrass
finally some fresh ginger
peel
slice nice and thinly
time now
to turn them over
and let the other half for a wonderful
flavor
to stop
in
bring the stock up to the boil turn the
gas up and then add the coconut milk
and I want the coconut milk just sitting
underneath the the top of a meeple
coconut milk in
and that sort of
gives it that creamy richness but it's
not heavy it's a fragrant light richness
before we start simmering check the
seasoning
that nice soft texture of the meatball
but that fragrance light richness of the
coconut broth it's going to cook those
meatballs perfectly
bring the broth up to the boil
and simmer gently for eight to ten
minutes
touch them with your finger they should
be slightly pliable but slightly springy
gas off I'm gonna finish it off with
something light and fresh zest of lime
but I want the zest
on top of the meatball
sort of cut through that richness and
then finally
squeeze fresh lime
and that just gives it that nice zesty
amazing taste
stirring the juice
it's got that kick and that vibrant
taste now the exciting part
when you come to serve it be generous
with that coconut broth talk the pan
get a good couple of ladles of a broth
in
meatball
[Music]
and that is a very
delicious way of eating a old-fashioned
meatball and bringing it into the 21st
century and they're just as good cooked
from Frozen as well
[Music]
the secret to stress-free cooking is
making it easy for yourself here are
three more recipes all based on my
delicious freezer friendly meatballs
just defrost them before you get started
first up beef meatballs with ariketti
kale and pine nuts
[Music]
meatballs to Hot Oil
Brown
meanwhile cook origetti pasta
then add chopped garlic to the meatballs
and shreddy kale a delicious green veg
packed with vitamins which Cooks in
minutes
cabbage is a great alternative if you
can't get kale
put in some of the cooking water from
the pasta to steam through
when the pasta is cooked al dente drain
and add to the meatballs season
then finish with sweet buttery pine nuts
and grated fresh Parmesan cheese
meatballs with olive keti kale and pine
nuts from meatballs to meal in minutes
my next easy standby supper is beef
meatball sandwich with melting
mozzarella and tomato salsa
[Music]
top a lightly Toasted Roll with
pan-fried meatballs then tear up chunks
of creamy buffalo mozzarella pile it on
and melt it under the grill
for the Tangy salsa sliced sweet red
onion then add juicy diced tomatoes and
roughly chopped fresh coriander
Eason and drizzle with olive oil
spoon over
[Music]
perfect in a Flash beef meatball
sandwich with melting mozzarella and a
tomato salsa a sandwich to die for
[Music]
my final super easy meatball recipe is
fiery meatball soup
[Music]
foreign
chopped onion and finely slice garlic in
hot olive oil
cumin seeds for warmth
and add your meatballs
cook on a high heat to get all those
aromatic flavors out
once the meatballs are browned add hot
chili paste for a spicy kick
tinned tomatoes
dried oregano and a liter of beef stock
[Music]
then simmer
next add sweet corn
and chopped courgettes
to finish add hot jalapeno peppers chop
fresh coriander and crushed tortilla
chips
and pop meatball wonder that really
packs a punch fiery meatball soup
[Music]
one versatile meatball recipe four
deliciously different dishes food that's
certain to make your life in the kitchen
easier and stress-free amazing whether
you're making great food to freeze or to
take straight to the table you need to
know how to shop for the best
ingredients
next up my shopping guide to oils
it doesn't matter if you're baking
frying or dressing salads using the
right oil can dramatically alter The
Taste and texture
here are the most common oils and what
to use them for
sunflower oil is a good value
all-rounder nice and light for frying
bacon in dressings and spicy dishes
ground nuts or peanut oil is great for
cooking on high heat as it gets really
hot without burning
sesame oil I flavoursome sweet and nutty
oil perfect sprinkled over Asian dishes
before serving
rapeseed oil is a healthier choice for
using in salads
I love walnut oil fantastically fragrant
it's brilliant for salad dressings and
it gives cakes a distinctive flavor
oil I use most in my cooking is olive
oil
[Music]
find some of the best olive oils sold in
Britain to go to one of the most
unlikely places
an electrical shop in London's East End
[Music]
turkish-born Mehmet morat has olive oil
in his blood my families produce this
olive oil for centuries what he doesn't
know about it isn't worth knowing
the very best extra virgin olive oil is
first cold pressed it's actually pressed
by Stone and then it's put for a
centrifugal spinner which spins out all
the bitter Waters and then you've got
pure olive oil cold pressed olive oil
and you've got to taste it to believe it
pour a little sample
slurp it draw it in without don't
swallow it warm it in your mouth coat
the whole of the inside of your mouth
with it and then swallow it will go down
like fruit juice and it will leave no
grease in a solar oiliness in your mouth
whatsoever
absolutely Sensational beautiful
my favorite use of any olive oils is to
pour it into a bowl room temperature rub
some wild oregano into it and get some
fresh busty bread and just dip it
there's food on its own don't eat
anything else
welcome back to my ultimate cookery
course
next on my guide to making it easy I'll
be creating a sweet treat to drool over
I want the chocolate a little
matchsticks dotted around but first
my quick guide to the basic kit you need
to get cooking fantastic food
you don't need to spend a fortune on
masses of kitchen equipment here are
three more Kitchen Essentials
whisk spoon and spatula
these three items are so cheap yet they
are so important to Great home cooking
a whisk there's so much more control
when you've got something whisking in
your hand you can gauge it so much
better than you can if it's an electric
mixer
bigger the balloon on your hand whisk
the faster it will whip as it draws in
more air Wooden Spoons don't scratch
pans they should be washed by hand
spatulas are indispensable for baking or
mixing make sure it's heat resistant so
it doesn't melt but more importantly
phenomenal for making
omelettes great with scrambled eggs and
you waste nothing because the spatula
almost cleans the bowl instantly
with these three you'll be well on your
way to cooking like a pro
and you'll need all three for my next
recipe
[Music]
my take on classic chocolate brownies is
guaranteed to put a smile on anyone's
face and not just when they're fresh out
of the oven
blondies
stock up on these delicious blondies
they'll keep for up to a week and it's a
great way of getting ahead if you're
expecting guests around
first off melt the butter for the
mixture
we've had hundreds and hundreds of
brownies the sort of white chocolate
version I.E blondies are amazing a
little bit more subtle keep a little
knob of butter
for the end just to grease your baking
tray turn the gas down
gently melt that butter
sugar into the bowl
[Music]
let's give that butter a little whisk
it sort of makes the mixture a bit
lighter slightly fluffy
off with the gas
a pinch of salt in the sugar then make a
little well in the middle
and sort of whisk you can see
it's already gone nice and blunt
love it
give that a really good mix
and the secret with the butter be
slightly warm sort of it melts the sugar
lovely
a teaspoon of vanilla extract in
next lightning whisk in two whole eggs
to give a little beat
this is such a delicious recipe yeah
it's so simple whisking the eggs looking
for that nice sort of rich
taste just smooth paste
see why we call these blondies beautiful
next teaspoon of baking powder baking
powder in and half a teaspoon of baking
soda
aerates the mixture it gives it that
little tartness you'll see the sort of
Rise instantly the minute they hit the
oven
and then your flour whisk with one hand
and just
slowly add half the flour first
get that all mixed up make sure that
mixture is really nice and smooth
check it occasionally
no lumps half a flour in
and then the other half and you'll feel
it sort of almost nice and firm
and that's why it's so important to add
the flowering stages this stops the
mixture going lumpy it should be just
dropping off the Whisk
beautiful
change over from a whisk to a spoon
next I want some texture some nice sweet
chewiness to the blondies dried
cranberries they bake beautifully but it
gives the Blondie a really nice sort of
chewy sweetness in the center next and
white chocolate
[Music]
I'm not going to grate it just chop it
up just slice it like little bits of
shrapnel
I want the chocolate my little
matchsticks dotted around
now chocolate in lovely fold that in I
want a nice even distribution of those
wonderful dried cranberries
don't over mix it I want to break up
that chocolate
nice even mix of cranberries and
chocolate
see the chocolate there'll be parts of
the chocolate in the oven that will
actually melt it'll be like little pools
of white melted chocolate in the center
now baking tray
small little knob of butter
and the grease baking tray and line it
some greaseproof paper and just over
extend it
shiny side out dull side hits the bottom
of the tray in
creased proof allows me to maximize on
the white chocolate inside the mix my
grease with paper the chocolate can melt
and almost stick to the tray so the
paper is just a really nice insurance
policy secondly we want that rise and
that sort of crispness now with the mix
get your spatula all the way around I
don't see anything left in that bowl
position the ball over your tray
nice and carefully
don't leave that slice in the bowl
nobody's licking that one and then just
take the back of a spatula go into the
corners push and come back into the
middle
turn the tray around let it work to your
advantage
try and get it evenly positioned in the
tray
if it goes in even
it Cooks evenly
make sure you smooth out the top of the
Blondie with the back of the spatula
and then into the oven it's going to
rise it's nice and crisp on that soft
gooeyness in the center
make your blondies at 180 degrees for 35
to 40 minutes
foreign
Edge on the outside and that sort of
soft gooey Center
leave that to cool down and it's going
to sort of firm up and wrinkle but it'll
stay nice and gooey in the center once
it's cooled down take it out and start
slicing
[Music]
after watching blondies a fantastic easy
treat to have on hand for yourself or to
share
[Music]
tricks the trade and kitchen tips
to make your life easier make sure you
make the most of your freezer my tip for
amazing tuna carpaccio is to freeze it
first and it will slice beautifully
why is the safe leftover wine for
cooking my tip is to freeze the
remaining wine and freezer bags or ice
cube trays it's great in stocks and
sauces
when you freeze soups or stews in tubs
the tip is not to overfill them leave
room to expand in the container
great tip for a cheap homemade ice cream
by a high quality vanilla ice cream and
make it your own by mixing in berries
chocolate or my favorite rum and boozy
raisins
[Music]
a fantastic tip for leftover lemons and
limes is to cut them into wedges freeze
and use them like ice cubes they won't
water down your drink and they'll also
add flavor
[Music]
Follow My ultimate cookery course
crammed with key lessons
top tips 100 recipes to stay your life
on and you'll literally be cooking
yourself into a better chef
many of these amazing recipes are on my
app please check out the app store for
details
go on get cooking